et notre invité politique c'est
françois-xavier bellamy bonjour merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous ce matin
j'étais un membre à des républicains on
est ensemble pendant 20 minutes pour une
interview en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale représente une
arme pascal jalabert bonjour pascal les
journaux du groupe ebra les journaux
régionaux de l'est de la france on
entendait patrick kanner à l'instant
votre réaction également aussi
françois-xavier bellamy à ce discours d'
emmanuel macron sur le séparatisme les
séparatismes comme il dit maintenant ce
discours qui est est attendue
c'était le bon discours qu'a prononcé le
président de la république pour vous
d'abord on n'a pas besoin de discours on
a besoin d'actes maintenant on est dans
une situation d'urgence vitale pour
l'avenir de la france je n'ai pas peur
de le dire
et face à cette urgence vitale il me
semble que la réponse est au mieux
insuffisante au pire dangereuse par
certains aspects insuffisante parce que
de fait il ne suffit pas de ces mesures
dont patrick kanner disait qu'elle était
effectivement très dispersés très
sporadiques pour pouvoir faire face à
l'adversaire devant lequel nous sommes
et je crois en particulier qu'il ne
suffira pas d'appliquer des réponses
juridiques un problème politique
c'est un adversaire politique que nous
devons affronter c'est l'islamisme c'est
l'islam politique qui veut fracturé la
société française est au fond je crois
que avant de rajouter des nouvelles lois
tous les acteurs de terrain le disent
d'ailleurs il faut d'abord commencer par
faire appliquer nos lois par faire
appliquer les lois qui existent déjà
donc une réponse insuffisante et même
dangereuse par certains aspects
dangereuses parce qu'elle alimente la
culture de l'excusé qui a fait et de ce
point de vue là patrick anr est
évidemment porte avec son camp en tous
les cas une part de la responsabilité de
la situation dans laquelle nous sommes
au fond le président de la république ne
rompt pas avec cette culture des excuses
qui a été le propre de la gauche pendant
très longtemps
il explique encore une fois que c'est de
la faute de la france si ces jeunes se
radicalise que c'est parce que nous
n'avons pas su tenir la promesse
républicaine
bien sûr il faut lutter pour que
l'égalité des chances soient mieux
respectés en france bien sûr il faut en
particulier et ça a été mon premier
engagement personnel et politique
lutter pour une éducation nationale qui
puisse vraiment offrir à chaque enfant
les moyens d'accomplir ses talents mais
enfin
beaucoup de zones rurales en france dans
beaucoup de zones de la france
périphérique
il y a aussi des inégalités et pour
autant il n'y a pas de jeunes qui
commettent des attentats
nous ne sommes pas devant un problème
lié à la fragilité de légalité en france
nous sommes devant un problème mondial
qui est celui de la propagation d'un
islam qui veut détruire ce qui fait
l'unité des sociétés occidentales
devant cet islam politique qui veut
s'imposer par la terreur et par la force
et c'est à cela qu'il faut répondre et
on y répondra pas plus de fermer
répondra pas en accusant la république
quelle incroyable fragilité que ce
président de la république qui nous
explique que c'est de la faute de la
france si aujourd'hui des attentats sont
commis sur le sol français touchant des
français et faisant des victimes
innocentes
quelle incroyable fragilité de la part
d'un président de la république qui pour
toujours donné des gages poursuit la
fuite en avant
je reviens à la question de l'éducation
que je voudrais partager un point qui
m'a qui m'a beaucoup marqué
l'apprentissage de l'arabe le président
de la république nous dit voilà il faut
que la france s'adresse à chacun des
jeunes qui sont sur son sol et il faut
en particulier développer
l'apprentissage de l'arabe à l'école moi
je crois que le vrai problème en france
aujourd'hui c'est l'apprentissage du
français que quand vous avez un jeune
français sur cinq à sa majorité qui
essaient la statistique officielle qui
nous le dit en difficulté dans la
maîtrise de la lecture et de l'écriture
du français
je crois que l'urgence c'est d'apprendre
à tous les enfants de france leur langue
parce que c'est leur langue s'ils sont
français
il n'y a aucune raison de perpétuer sur
le sol français
une pluralité de communautés de langues
différentes et que je crois que l'armada
le ministre de l'intérieur dit qu'il
vaut mieux que ces enfants apprennent
l'arabe à l'école parce que sinon
liseron la prendre dans les mosquées et
que je le cite l'enseigné à l'école
c'est aussi un moyen de réduire le
pouvoir religieux
est-ce qu'il n'a pas raison mais je
crois qu'il faut de d'étonnantes
démission soit une curieuse naïveté de
la part du ministre de l'intérieur
d'abord qui peut croire une seule
seconde que les enfants qui aujourd'hui
suivent des cours d'arabe à la mosquée
dans des écoles tenues par des religieux
ou même d'ailleurs dans les locaux
qu'ils sont
vous le savez aujourd'hui l'occasion
pour l'islam d'autres pays d'entrer dans
notre propre système éducatif qui peut
croire que pour ces jeunes apprendre
l'islam se fera de manière équivalente
dans l'école de la république
on le sait les cours d'arabe ne sont pas
que des cours d'arabe et il faut ne rien
connaître à la culture de ces familles à
la culture musulmane pour ne pas savoir
que l'arabe est aussi et peut-être même
d'abord une langue religieuse c'est une
langue qui porte avec elle le coran
c'est la langue sacrée et apprendre
l'arabe c'est nécessairement suivre un
cours d'une nature religieuse et
confessionnelle
pour beaucoup de ces jeunes là je ne dis
pas que on ne puisse pas apprendre
l'arabe comme langue mais en tous les
cas pour les familles qui choisissent de
transmettre l'enseignement de l'arabe à
leurs enfants via des formations
religieuses
il est clair que ces familles là ne se
tourneront pas et c'est déjà le cas
aujourd'hui vers l'école de la
république pour proposer un enseignement
laïque de l'arabe à leurs enfants et
surtout le point le plus important c'est
que gérard jerald à lundi après tout on
enseigne aussi d'autres langues vivantes
à l'école et d'autres enfants apprennent
le portugais l'italien l'allemand mais
enfin quand même
ne confondons pas tout nous nous avons
un défi majeur en matière d'intégration
nous héritons d'une faillite collective
immense sur ce sujet là il n'y a pas
aujourd'hui dans notre pays une
communauté de germanophones qui a du mal
à s'intégrer à la communauté nationale
la ram n'est pas une langue vivante
parmi d'autres aujourd'hui pour la
france il y à un défi majeur qui est
celui de faire que tous ces enfants se
sont complètement français qu'ils le
soient et ils en ont le droit
et il le mérite ils méritent qu'on leur
dise tu es français tu n'as pas à
entretenir une forme de double culture
de double identité
il faut que tu puisse participer
pleinement à la communauté nationale
et de ce point de vue là lutter vraiment
contre le séparatisme et regardez le
contraste incroyable lutter vraiment
contre le séparatisme ça n'est pas
promettre qu'on va apprendre plus
l'arabe à l'école aux enfants c'est leur
promettre qu'on va leur apprendre enfin
à tous à parler parfaitement le français
à écrire parfaitement leur langue c'est
leur langue il leur appartient de droit
et nous devons la leur transmettre si
nous voulons reconstruire une société
qui puisse connaître ce qui fait le lien
de son unité demain c'est la langue mais
ça n'est pas seulement la langue à
travers
c'est la culture c'est le sentiment
d'appartenance c'est la capacité de
s'intégrer pleinement à la vie d'un pays
dans toutes ses dimensions dans la vie
de leur pays encore une fois je le
répète et je ne comprends pas que
derrière l'idée de lutter contre le
séparatisme on entretienne en réalité ce
qui fait la fracturation de notre
société et ce qui alimente évidemment la
pluralité de dire que même au delà
risque qui se font dire demain est-ce
que emmanuel macron si on suit votre
raisonnement il a affaibli la république
avec son discours je crois que par
certains aspects oui c'est le cas
exactement comme quand qu'encore une
fois il reprend cette culture de
l'excusé quand dans son discours de
nouveau il répète que la france n'est
pas sortie d'un surmoi post coloniale
qui l'attaquent en fait la france pour
la violence qu'elle subit c'est
absolument incroyable et ça alimente en
réalité cette espèce de ressentiment qui
forment le séparatisme qu'ensuite il dit
déplorer si nous voulons lutter contre
le séparatisme alors nous devons dire à
ces jeunes ce qui est la pure vérité que
la france veut leur offrir ce qu'elle a
à lui donner de meilleurs que la france
arrête de se flageller que la france
n'est pas coupable pour le terrorisme
qu'elle subit comme tant de nations
occidentales et qu'elle va lutter de
manière déterminée contre ceux qui
veulent lui imposer ce projet politique
et ça ne passe pas d'abord par le fait
je le disais tout à l'heure de rajouter
de nouvelles lois ça passe par le fait
de faire accepter le nomme manière je ne
vois pas en quoi elle dépassera
malheureusement les artifices de
communication
il ya certainement des ajustements
législatifs à opérer mais on le voit
très bien dans notre pays aujourd'hui il
y à des lieux entiers qui sont des zones
de non-droit dans lequel la loi n'est
plus appliquée dans lesquels on n'ose
plus faire appliquer la loi
à quoi cela servira-t-il de rajouter de
nouvelles règles sinon règles déjà
existantes de toute façon son team sont
inopérantes très mal passé à l'autre
actualité l'autre actualité ce sont ces
nouvelles mesures annoncées hier par un
oui alors le gouvernement avait promis
beaucoup de concertation a mis en place
des mesures locales
comment jugez-vous la gestion de la
crise globalement écouter la critique
est facile et là est difficile et je ne
voudrais pas donner le sentiment de
faire la leçon au gouvernement sur un
sur un sujet si délicat
je dirais simplement deux choses que je
dis comme un citoyen parmi d'autres qui
n'a pas plus d'informations que beaucoup
de citoyens et c'est vrai que nous
sommes tous un peu dans la même
situation d'incertitude et de 2,2 et
d'anxiété aussi il faut bien le dire
aujourd'hui
la pire chose que je voudrais dire c'est
que dans ce moment d'incertitude on
aurait besoin que l'état soit celui qui
justement donne un cap clair fixe des
règles claires et simples
aujourd'hui on a le sentiment d'avoir
changé sans arrêt d'indicateurs on ne
sait plus exactement à quel référentiel
se vouer on ne sait plus ce que vous
dites ce que veut le dire et les
couleurs dont on nous a gratifié au
cours des dernières semaines au point au
fond que tout cela créé une situation
qui rend très difficile la prise de
décision y compris pour pour des pour
des acteurs du monde économique du monde
culturel jeu j'ai repris à paris il ya
quelques jours un cycle de conférences
de philosophie qui se tient dans un
théâtre depuis des années je le vois à
travers cette expérience au théâtre
cette difficulté que beaucoup d'acteurs
du monde de la culture aujourd'hui de
savoir dans quelle direction aller
et au fond on aurait besoin que le
gouvernement malgré cette incertitude
puissent donner des orientations plus
clair on ne peut pas rentrer je sais que
la maire de paris leur disait récemment
dans une logique d'aller retour
permanent de stop and go 10 et elle je
préfère le dire en français mais c'est
vrai qu'il ya quelque chose de juste
c'est que au fond tout le monde est un
peu perdu et qu'on aurait besoin
d'orientations et bancal rapidement
qu'un capitaine pour vous en tous les
cas il manque un cap qui soient plus
claires et puis je crois des critères de
discernement de décisions qui soient
plus objective et encore une fois c'est
difficile c'est compliqué je ne dis pas
le contraire mais on en a besoin aussi
pour protéger nos libertés
et c'est le deuxième point que je
voudrais souligner on est dans un moment
qui est évidemment difficile mais dans
lequel il faut réaffirmer que nos droits
fondamentaux que les libertés
fondamentales elles ne valent pas
seulement pour les périodes de calme et
de sérénité
elles valent encore plus sans doute pour
les moments de tensions et de
difficultés
et aujourd'hui on a le sentiment que
derrière cette incertitude des critères
se fait jour au fond une place de
l'arbitraire dans la décision politique
qui touche à des libertés fondamentales
qui a quelque chose d'un peu inquiétant
je trouve un mot sur le parlement
européen par rapport à la crise du coc
vide tout s'est recentré à bruxelles et
à strasbourg
on est très inquiet de ce qui est en
train de se passer quelle est votre
position là dessus je crois qu'il faut
défendre bien sûr le siège du parlement
européen à strasbourg c'est fondamental
évidemment la période actuelle rend
difficile le fait de faire des sessions
à strasbourg
je crois que d'une manière plus générale
il est absolument capital si nous
voulons sauver le siège du parlement à
strasbourg que nous ayons une stratégie
claire sur ce sujet une stratégie à
l'horizon de dix vingt ou trente ans
pour faire revenir le parlement européen
à strasbourg
il est absurde les députés européens
sont très nombreux à le dire ils sont
très majoritaires a critiqué ce
processus et les citoyens aussi sont
très nombreux à ne pas le comprendre il
est un peu absurde de faire
l'aller-retour une fois par mois entre
bruxelles et strasbourg
si nous voulons faire en sorte que le
parlement européen prenne vraiment un
racines à strasbourg il faut qu ils s'y
installent complètement évidemment ça ne
se fera pas demain mais il faut qu'à
horizon de dix quinze vingt ans nous
ayons une vraie stratégie pour faire en
sorte que le parlement s'installe
vraiment à strasbourg et de ce point de
vue là la crise que nous vivons est une
opportunité parce qu'elle nous a permis
de redécouvrir que avec le télétravail
avec les visioconférences avec toute la
technologie qui se développe aujourd'hui
on avait de moins en moins besoin d'être
collé en permanence à nos interlocuteurs
on n'a pas besoin d'être à bruxelles
dans les jupes de la commission pour
faire un travail efficace au parlement
européen on peut le faire de strasbourg
et ce serait aussi une manière de dire
que le parlement n'a pas vocation à être
perpétuellement l'institution qui suit
la commission et le conseil
ce serait une manière de donner tout son
sens à ces lieux démocratique de la vie
de nos pays l'autre actualité ce sont
les calédoniens qui se sont prononcés
hier et qui ont voté contre leur
indépendance à plus de 53%
mais il ya quand même une progression du
oui par rapport au dernier référendum
comment vous avez accueilli ces
résultats avec une très grande joie
d'ailleurs
d'abord parce que parce que la nouvelle
calédonie n'est pas une région qui
aurait rejoint la france par hasard ça
n'est pas un archipel qui par les
circonstances de l'histoire aurait été
placé sous la tutelle de la france
la nouvelle calédonie c'est la france et
bien sûr nous avons encore beaucoup de
chemin à faire pour que cette unité de
la république y compris outre mer soit
une réalité concrète pour tous les
citoyens français
bien sûr nous avons encore beaucoup de
travail à faire pour qu'en nouvelle
calédonie la république progresse
vraiment et offre à chacun la même
chance mais je crois qu'il est
fondamental que la nouvelle calédonie et
redit son attachement à la france
et si un troisième référendum devait
avoir lieu nous avons du travail à faire
pour pouvoir faire progresser
cet attachement à la france pour faire
progresser le camp loyaliste en tous les
cas je m'y engagerai de toutes mes
forces je devais aller en nouvelle
calédonie dans les semaines écoulées
la crise actuelle m'en a empêché
j'espère pouvoir y aller le plus
rapidement possible en tous les cas
avant ce troisième référendum si
possible il ya beaucoup de sujets on va
dire qu'il faut qu'il faut tenir
il est prévu par les accords n est pas
obligatoire pour vous il faut le tenir
moi je crois que cette stratégie était
absurde au fond on voit bien la
répétition des votes a finalement très
peu de sens
il me semble qu'on devrait pouvoir
s'arrêter à ce référendum de référendum
sont venus dans un temps relativement
court redire l'attachement de la
nouvelle académie à la france voilà
maintenant ce sera à la décision des
élus de de nouvelle calédonie en tous
les cas s'il devait avoir lieu
j'espère pouvoir me rendre avant qu'il
se déroule on a des sujets européens
majeurs sur place et il ya aussi bien
sûr la nouvelle calédonie était avant
postes de cela un sujet un sujet global
parce que la nouvelle colonie fait face
à la chine dont on voit aujourd'hui à
quel point son rouleau compresseur
cherchent à écraser toute singularité à
se saisir de toutes les opportunités qui
peuvent intéresser le régime chinois
il me semble qu'il est important que la
france puisse redire que la nouvelle
calédonie est un lieu de liberté un lieu
bien sûr où son influence pour rayonner
mais aussi et surtout un lieu qui peut
faire vivre les coutumes de cet archipel
et c'est je crois un enjeu majeur pour
la france et pour l'europe aussi dans
son ancien justement puisque vous parlez
de l'europe on va passer au dossier de
l'union européenne vous étiez en grèce
il y a quelques jours qu'elle était
l'objet de ce déplacement
j'ai été en grèce d'abord pour redire
notre soutien à nos amis grecs face aux
menaces que fait peser cieux le
comportement de la turquie aujourd'hui
c'est un sujet dont on parle trop peu
mais avec arnaud danjean qui est un de
mes collègues de la délégation française
au parlement européen qui est dans la
commission des affaires étrangères et
qui s'occupe beaucoup des questions de
défense et de sécurité
nous avons voulu attirer l'attention sur
ce qui se joue aux portes de l'europe
dans ce rapport avec la turquie dont le
comportement est devenu extrêmement
agressif
la turquie a violé l'espace maritime de
la grèce de manière impunis pendant des
semaines
elle viole l'espace aérien de la grèce
de manière répétée depuis de trop
nombreuses années elle occupe une partie
de chypre aujourd'hui par la force et au
fond ce qui se joue dans ce comportement
de la turquie c'est une menace qui ne
touche pas seulement la grèce mais qui
concerne l'europe dans son ensemble la
turquie juste avant la crise du grenat
virus vous vous en souvenez sans doute
avait organisé une véritable crise
migratoire à la frontière de la grèce et
de la bulgarie
en faisant venir elle même des personnes
parfois même des détenus à la frontière
de la grèce pourrait faire rentrer en
europe
je crois que nous ne pouvons pas tolérer
ce comportement est que l'europe parle
d'une voix trop faible sur ce sujet je
suis heureux que le président de
république et montrer la solidarité de
la france envers la grèce dans cette
période là en envoyant notamment notre
marine nationale sur place mais
aujourd'hui l'europe et le conseil qui
s'est déroulé il ya quelques jours l'a
montré une fois de plus n'arrive pas à
parler avec force pour dire que monsieur
erdogan doit s'arrêter et pour menacer
de sanctions
le régime de monsieur erdogan s'il
franchissait de nouveau celui ci n'a pas
doté de fonctions qui ajuste menacé de
deux punitions
si les provocations continues et pour
vous c'est quoi c'est l'union européenne
trop faible bien sûr beaucoup trop
faible il faut évidemment réagir d'une
manière plus forte il faut mettre fin
tout de suite au processus d'adhésion de
la turquie avec l'union européenne nous
le répétons depuis des mois maintenant
mais c'est devenu une aberration que ce
processus se poursuive il faut suspendre
les fonds qui sont versés à la turquie
et nour déposeront un amendement en ce
sens dans quelques jours au parlement
européen parce qu'il est inconcevable
que l'union européenne aujourd'hui ne
réagissent pas avec force face à la
turquie disons le derrière cette
faiblesse il ya évidemment le risque que
fait peser sur nous je le disais tout à
l'heure la fracturation de nos sociétés
la peur au fond que des citoyens dans
nos pays prennent fait et cause pour la
turquie ci l'europe parlait trop fort je
crois que c'est le moment de faire
respecter nos principes et il est temps
de réagir la turquie intervient aussi
dans le conflit du haut karabagh dans le
caucase là aussi je l'europe l'hôtel
intervenir plus fermement
bien sûr j'ai signé une tribune hier
avec plusieurs dizaines de
parlementaires et d'élus dans le journal
dimanche sur ce sujet il est absolument
indispensable que nous puissions dire
notre soutien et non pas seulement le
dire mais le montrer par la force
c'est à dire par le fait de mettre en
oeuvre la aussi des sanctions précises
contre le régime aziri qui menacent de
déstabiliser toute la région que nous
puissions témoigner ainsi concrètement
de notre soutien à l'arménie qui est
nous le savons un pays déjà martyrs de
tant de drames du xxème siècle une
communauté touchée par la violence et
par le génocide de la turquie continue
de nier aujourd'hui nous avons le devoir
maintenant de réagir
l'europe ne sera forte que si les pays
européens sont capables de se faire
respecter de re de revenir à une logique
de puissance qu'ils ont pendant trop
longtemps abdiqué et c'est sur ces
sujets là qu'il faut bien sûr le montrer
le tract eu alité à l'union européenne
c'est le plan de relance vous avez été
chargé vous par le ppe et le parti de la
droite européenne pour le dire un petit
peu simplement de travailler sur le plan
de relance européen le plan proposé
n'est pas le bon pour vous en tous les
cas nous allons tout faire pour faire en
sorte qu'il soit le plus efficace
possible
je me suis opposé depuis le début de ce
débat et je les dis à de nombreuses
reprises à son mode de financement
je crois que créer un emprunt européen
n'était pas la bonne réponse
maintenant il est évident que puisque
cet emprunt a été décidée par le conseil
par les chefs d'état et de gouvernement
sans que nous puissions avoir de
capacité d'action sur ce sujet bien il
faut que nous puissions faire en sorte
qu'au moins cet argent qui est empruntée
aux futures générations soit dépenser de
la manière la plus rationnelle possible
et surtout soient engagées dans des
investissements susceptibles de produire
une prospérité future qui permettra à
ces générations de demain de rembourser
la charge de la dette que nous l'aurons
transféré c'est le travail que je mène
effectivement comme rapporteur sur ce
sujet faire en sorte que c'est ce que
j'ai appelée la clause du futur
l'engagement envers les générations à
venir faire en sorte comment cet argent
soit investi dans des projets
susceptibles de nous garantir demain une
forme de prospérité future et je crois
que c'est absolument crucial parce que
le grand risque c'est que tout cet
argent c'est 750 milliards d'euros soit
dilapidé pour amortir le choc pour la
génération d'aujourd'hui sans rien
laisser à ceux qui suivront et ce serait
évidemment les trahir que de céder à
cette facilité une fois de plus
cette facilité que nous avons tellement
connue dans notre endettement français
qui fait que nous laissons à ceux qui
viendront après nous à la fois une dette
immense et aussi une marge de manoeuvre
pour réagir aux crises futures qui ne
manqueront pas d'arriver qui était
évidemment très atrophiée allez on va
terminer en parlant de votre party les
républicains et ce sondage publié hier
dans le journal du dimanche qui a testé
plusieurs hypothèses à droite c'est
xavier bertrand qui est de me placer
mieux placé que valérie pécresse que
bruno retailleau que françois baroin
alors c'est un sondage on est très loin
de la présidentielle mais qu'en
avez-vous pensé
moi je vais vous dire très simplement je
ne comprends pas ces sondages des
candidats que vous avez montré à l'écran
d'abord lesquels sont candidats lesquels
ont déclaré leurs candidats dans quel
cadre dans quels cas dans quelle partie
par quel processus et surtout et c'est
le plus important
sur quelle ligne avec quelle idée mais
je crois que c'est moins bruno
retailleau et xavier bertrand ne s'en
cache pas mais rue l'occasion de faire
des propositions de développer un
programme une vision de nous dire ce
qu'il voulait pour la france via la vie
politique française se meurt de cet
excès d'intérêt pour les individualités
au détriment des idées ce dont nous
avons besoin aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
d'abord de deux personnalités ce dont
nous avons besoin c'est d'une ligne
claire et ce dont la droite a besoin
surtout c'est d'une ligne claire et je
crois qu'elle ne l'obtiendra pas sans un
vrai débat ouvert sans une conversation
qui permettent avec les électeurs
d'ailleurs de trancher sur notre lignée
de trancher sur le fond
chacun peut faire quand même y compris
sur la ligne que ce soit sur la ligne ou
sur les personnalités
il ya de fortes divergences donc comment
on tranche j'ai déjà eu l'occasion de le
dire je suis pas un passionné des
questions de 2,2 d'organisations de
partis de campagne électorale mais
évidemment la politique passe aussi par
là et je crois je le disais tout à
l'heure que la droite ne s'en sortira
pas si elle ne se donne pas l'occasion
d'un rendez vous démocratique qui
permettent de trancher sur le fond et
sur la ligne notre famille politique que
réfléchi à ces sujets là de manière tout
à fait paisible
mais je crois que il faut continuer de
réfléchir à la manière dont on va
organiser ce que gérard larcher dans
cette maison ici au sénat appelle un
processus de départage voilà nous y
viendrons sans aucun doute
pour l'instant nous avons travaillé
seuls militants encore une fois c'est
une discussion qu'il faut avoir à
l'intérieur du parti j'ai pas j'ai pas
de jets pas de da priori sur ce sujet
mais ce que je vois c'est que il y a
plusieurs candidats ce que je vois vous
le disiez tout à l'heure c'est qu'il ya
aussi une diversité de lignes possibles
et et moi je crois encore une fois qu'
il ne peut pas y avoir pour la droite de
crédibilité retrouvée
si elle ne commence pas d'abord par
organiser cette discussion entre ses
principales figures sur le terrain des
idées parce que c'est ce qui
concrètement au delà des questions de
personnes quand on regarde ce sondage
hier ce qui frappe aussi c'est que
emmanuel macron et marine le pen sont
largement devant le candidat de la
droite quel qu'il soit est ce que
finalement christian estrosi n'a pas
raison quand il parle de candidature de
témoignage
christian estrosi a raison de pointer
sans aucun doute la crise profonde que
traverse notre famille politique
évidemment elle est incontestable en
revanche il a absolument tort lorsqu'il
pense que nous pourrions remédier à
cette crise en acceptant de nous
dissoudre dans le maquereau nisme le
maquereau nisme aujourd'hui fait la
preuve de son échec
et si il était possible pour certains de
se laisser piéger par l'illusion en 2017
je ne vois vraiment pas quelle est la
raison qui nous pousserait à hisser dès
maintenant après trois ans d'exercice du
pouvoir qui de mon point de vue en tout
les cas n'ont permis de résoudre aucun
des grands problèmes que traverse notre
pays aucun j'aimerais pouvoir me réjouir
de ce que mon pays va mieux après trois
ans de présidence d' emmanuel macron
mais ça n'est pas le cas et je ne dis
pas ça pour critiquer par pure facilité
au contraire je dis ça parce que cela
nous impose de prendre nos
responsabilités et d'offrir une
véritable alternance à la france
évidemment ce sera pour la droite un
défi immense
mais il n'est pas trop tard pour s'y
atteler et c'est ce que nous devons
faire dès maintenant et merci beaucoup
merci françois xavier merci d'avoir été
avec nous ce matin merci pascal jalabert
on regarde la une du dauphiné ce matin
pascal elbé marche blanche en hommage
blatche taurine à villefontaine dans le
nord-isère un hommage à cette jeune
fille qui a été retrouvée morte
dans une rivière probablement avec
l'intervention d'un tiers grande douleur
partagée par partout toute la commune et
merci beaucoup merci d'avoir été avec
nous parce tout de suite au club des
territoires la mutuelle nationale
territoriale
la mutuelle des agents des services
publics locaux vous présente le club des
territoires
angie acteurs engagés dans la transition
zéro carbone des régions vous présente
le club des territoires
[Musique]